quick what's your mental image of a
regular heroin user
probably not carl hart a 54 year old air
force veteran
who holds an endowed chair in psychology
at columbia university
he's also the author of the new book
drug use for grown-ups
in which he unabashedly cops to the fact
that he's been a
regular heroin user for the past five
years and declares it his
favorite drug for recreational use why
do you use heroin
why do people do alcohol to unwind to
relax
the same is true with my heroin use i
use heroin
in part because it's really good at
helping me
to unwind to be more forgiving of other
people
to look at my own behavior and see where
i need to modify
in order to be a more responsible person
in order to be a better person
it helps to make me a better person
because i can forget about
some of the sort of penny things that i
may have had
in my mind and then holding those things
against people
instead i learned how to be more
forgiving and more
magnanimous hart rides that he sniffs or
swallows his heroine
and he stresses that it's the impurities
and adulterants mixed in black market
heroin
that are particularly harmful and he
underscores to paraphrase spider-man
that with great drug use comes great
responsibility i meet my parental
personal and professional
responsibilities
i pay my taxes serve as a volunteer in
my community on a regular basis
and contribute to the global community
as an informed and engaged citizen
i am better for my drug use the
stereotype that all drug users are
addicts who can't control their behavior
is mostly drug war propaganda he says
and at odds with reality
my heroin use is just like my sort of
taking
time out to go to a club to see a
comedian perform or to go see a concert
i set aside that time for that activity
and i enjoy that activity in that moment
and when that moment
is over i'm done when you think about
something like methamphetamine it's been
documented about
five to ten percent of the people who
try methamphetamine
will meet criteria for uh addiction
something like heroin
somewhere between 20 and 30 percent of
the people who try heroin will become
addicted so what can clearly be seen is
that the vast majority of those folks
don't have problems related to addiction
if such percentages seem high
realize that they're in line with
lifetime occurrence of alcohol use
disorder
and that booze causes far more deaths
and health problems
than other intoxicants drug use for
grown-ups is a bracing manifesto that
calls for us to treat hard drugs
the same as beer wine and distilled
spirits
hart shares his personal experiences as
a way to help us see that
illegal substances are similar to the
ones we use without hesitation
on a daily basis he takes heroin out of
the shooting gallery and puts it back
in the family room oftentimes my drug
use is with my partner and so
we have discussions about our kids our
kid our youngest kid is 20 but
we just like any other parents we can be
paying in their asses to
our children and so how can we be better
parents how can we
support them in a more loving way in a
way that is more
effective in a way that is more
acceptable in a way
that they find more helpful hart says
prohibition has inflicted
incalculable damage by driving the drug
market underground
it's not just the attendant violence but
also the lack of brand reliability and
quality control and the drug war makes
it harder for people with substance
abuse problems to get help
since they have to admit to being
criminals as well as addicts as a black
man who grew up in a tough neighborhood
in miami in the crack crazed 80s
hart is especially attuned to how
prohibition
has devastated poor and minority
communities through overzealous policing
and mandatory sentencing but he says the
drug war's greatest sin
is against the founding ideals of
america as the home of the brave
and the land of the free what i'm trying
to do is ask americans to think about
their own liberty and not in this
jingleistic
false patriotic sense but in terms of
what the declaration of independence
guarantees life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness for all of us
as long as we don't disrupt anybody
else's ability to do the same
that means we get to live our life as we
choose as we see fit and taking drugs
can be a part of that and it is a part
of that for a lot of americans
this book is for grown-ups and i mean
people who are responsible they handle
their responsibilities
they are members of their community they
participate in their community
people who are autonomous people who are
responsible that's who i'm defining as
adults how would hart know if his use of
heroin amphetamines lsd mdma or other
substances
is getting out of hand i would know it's
problematic if
i'm failing to meet my responsibilities
that are important to me
you write a book you write you have
these deadlines and
i'm not making these deadlines because i
am
i don't know hung over from some drug
use whether it's heroin or something
else
i'm not making these deadlines because
i'm engaged in this behavior of using
this drug when i should have been
producing
i'm not meeting the obligations that i
made to my children when i started to
fall
short in those areas as a result of my
drug use then
that has to go the subtitle of heart's
book is
chasing liberty in the land of fear he
says it took him
so long to come out of the chemical
closet about his drug use
because he was worried about his
professional image
i was a coward i was afraid of the
blowback that would occur
if i said oh yeah of course i do a
little cocaine
mdma heroin there are millions of people
using these drugs
i had to look take a long look in the
mirror
and say all right we're vilifying people
who are
out of those drug users for having been
labeled a drug user and here i am doing
the same activity and i'm staying in the
closet what kind of man am i
and i wasn't happy with the person who
i was looking at in the mirror and so
that
helped to force me to get out of the
closet i no longer want to be a coward
[Music]